[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
metzger
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
an meiner seite ist norbert lehmann für
den sport als wunder von mir wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
diskussion um lockerung der korona
maßnahmen schleswig-holstein wagt einen
schritt zurück zur normalität experten
warnen
vorteil gegen hetze im netz das
bundesverfassungsgericht setzt der
meinungsfreiheit im internet engere
grenzen
und hilfe bei explodierenden
energiekosten das kabinett beschließt
eine einmalzahlung für geringverdiener
wann ist der richtige zeitpunkt um die
korona maßnahmen zu lockern die nachbarn
in dänemark haben gerade alle
abgeschafft trotz einer inzidenz von
5000 in deutschland hat heute schleswig
holstein als erstes bundesland deutliche
lockerung beschlossen und
bundesjustizminister buschmann stellt
eine öffnung im märz in aussicht
lena sünder buch fasst die diskussion
zusammen
schon in einer woche soll in schleswig
holstein die kontrolle von 2g nachweisen
in geschäften der vergangenheit
angehören stattdessen mehr normalität
nur die maske zu tragen soll dann
reichen schleswig holstein war mit
seinen niedrigen infektionszahlen lange
corona musterland hat aktuell eine
inzidenz von 895 2 und liegt damit
deutlich unter dem bundesdurchschnitt
zudem hat das land eine hohe impfquoten
keine kritische belegung der
intensivstationen nun prescht es mit den
lockerungen vor deutlich betont dass
unsere experte und experten immer schon
gesagt haben dass sie zweig im
einzelhandel nicht für geboten halten
sondern nur weil der ball ist bundesweit
galt und von daher gab es hier auch
klare rückendeckung dass dieser schritt
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt verantwortbar ist
für den bund hatte justizminister
buschmann vorsichtig lockerungen im märz
in aussicht gestellt die regierung
bleibt insgesamt aber zurückhaltend alle
voraussagen sind so dass wir im
augenblick weiter stark steigende zahlen
haben auch die krankenhaus belegungen
nehmen zu in vielen gebieten insofern
sehe ich nicht dass es im moment drängt
da eine
vorziehung beziehungsweise einen
fahrplan zu lockerungen schon
aufzustellen und verständnis auch beim
baden württembergischen
ministerpräsidenten er hat bereits
gestern deutlich gemacht nicht vor
ostern über corona lockerungen reden zu
wollen
brechen jetzt keine exit-strategie
debatte vom zaun das wäre völlig
unangemessen an völlig falsches signal
auch virologen raten weiterhin zur
vorsicht
ich glaube es ist weise sich das
vielleicht jetzt in schleswig holstein
erst mal anzuschauen noch ein bisschen
abzuwarten inwieweit solche lockerungen
dann ein effekt auf die zahlen haben ein
effekt auf die belastung in den
krankenhäusern haben und mit sie das
nicht tut dann kann man sicherlich über
breitere lockerungen nachdenken der
politik bleiben noch genau zwei wochen
zeit einen gemeinsamen kurs zu finden
bis zur nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
seit beginn der pandemie vor zwei jahren
wurden in deutschland mehr als zehn
millionen infektionen registriert
tatsächlich dürften es weitaus mehr sein
weil viele ansteckungen nicht erkannt
werden aktuell meldet das
robert-koch-institut
208.000 498 neue fälle binnen 24 stunden
44 1498 mehr als vergangenen mittwoch
196 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage in stents beträgt jetzt 1200
27,5 alle weiteren zahlen und analysen
die in der pandemie wichtig sind finden
sie im internet zum beispiel die
aktuellen impfquoten und die belegung
der krankenhäuser online auf zdf heute
oder in unserer zdf heute
die energiepreise schießen gerade durch
die decke benzin heizöl strom und gas
werden durchweg teurer und das bringt
viele menschen ernsthaft in bedrängnis
tanken etwa kostet so viel wie nie ein
liter super e10 liegt heute im schnitt
bei 1 euro 71 besonders extrem ist der
anstieg bei den heizkosten für öl
zahlten haushalte schon im herbst
mindestens 90 prozent als im jahr davor
im sommer droht die nächste kräftige
nachzahlungen
besonders bedürftigen will die regierung
jetzt mit einem einmaligen zuschuss
helfen romanesco war
vb lebt derzeit von arbeitslosengeld 1
sie möchte nicht erkannt werden auch ihr
gasanbieter kündigte im dezember
überraschend den vertrag für vier wochen
rutschte sehen die aktuell teils extrem
teure ersatzversorgung über 500 euro
musste sie zahlen für nicht mal einen
monat reserven hat sie nicht nur eine
kleine altersvorsorge ich habe meinen
spaß
dann angeschrieben dass die mir geld
auszahlen und das haben wir gemacht und
damit habe ich quasi die rechnung
bezahlt sonst wäre das nicht gegangen ja
und der würde eine katastrophe sein
schon jetzt haben viele bedürftige
energie schulden waren sozialverbände
die aktuellen preissprünge würden bei
vielen erst mit den neuen
jahresabrechnungen ankommen die lage sei
alarmierend wir gehen davon aus dass ein
erhöhter beratungsbedarf besteht und ein
jahr an auf die beratungsstellen auch
erfolgt insbesondere für die haushalte
die eben schon jetzt finanziell keine
ressourcen haben der geplante
heizkostenzuschuss der bundesregierung
sieht jetzt für alleinlebende
wohngeldbezieher einmalig 135 euro vor
für einen zwei-personen-haushalt sind es
175 für jeden weiteren mitbewohner
nochmal 35 euro auch azubis und bafög
empfänger sollen profitieren
verbraucherschützer kritisieren den
zuschuss als zu niedrig wir fordern
einen heizkosten zu schlag von
mindestens 500 euro durchschnittlich für
einen haushalt oder vielleicht sogar
noch deutlich mehr vbs der
schuldenspirale gerade noch entkommen
sie hat kurzfristig einen neuen job
gefunden
die rekord energiepreise bleiben aber
eine große belastung
wir bleiben beim thema energie die eu
hat große ziele und will bis 2050
klimaneutral sein um das zu erreichen
stuft die kommission gas und atomkraft
übergangsweise als klimafreundlich 1 das
stößt auf zum teil massive kritik erste
eu länder kündigten klagen an die
deutsche regierung sagt gas als
zwischenlösung jahr atomkraft nein aus
brüssel berichtet steuern
was ist eine grüne investition ist die
frage die sie heute beantworten und bei
der die eu kommission warnt dass ihre
entscheidungen kaum beifallsstürme
hervorruft der recht sagt von heute mag
vielleicht nicht perfekt sein aber er
ist eine lösung er hilft uns weiter auf
unserem weg in die klimaneutralität
die taxonomie der eu-kommission listet
auf welche energien als nachhaltig
gelten laut kommission auch atomkraft
und gas zumindest für eine übergangszeit
damit könnten milliarden euro von
privatinvestoren auch in diese
energieformen fließen
umweltorganisationen werfen der eu vor
so ihre eigenen klimaziele zu beerdigen
österreich kündigt eine klage an grüne
technologien dürfen keine signifikanten
umweltschäden anrichten das tut der
atomkraft aber das ist kurz dokumentiert
von fukushima bis tschernobyl politisch
gestoppt werden kann der vorschlag nur
noch auf zwei wegen mit einem veto von
20 der 27 regierungen die mindestens 65
prozent der eu bevölkerung
repräsentieren kaum wahrscheinlich oder
mit einer absoluten mehrheit im
eu-parlament denkbar es gibt einen
großen unmut im europäischen parlament
über diesen vorschlag ich halte die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das parlament in
am ende komplett ablehnt so groß erst
mal vier monate ist jetzt zeit den
entwurf zu prüfen auch die
bundesregierung will nun beraten wie sie
damit umgeht in der energiepolitik sind
sich europas staaten nicht grün die
einen wie frankreich setzen voll auf
atom andere wie deutschland haben sich
davon auf dauer verabschiedet die eu
kommission wollte es allen recht machen
und wird genau deshalb von fast allen
kritisiert
in der sich zuspitzenden ukraine krise
wollen die usa jetzt weitere militärs
nach europa verlegen ein pentagon
sprecher kündigte an dass in den
nächsten tagen rund 2000 soldaten aus
den usa nach deutschland und polen
geschickt würden aus deutschland
wiederum sollen dann 1000 soldaten nach
rumänien verlegt werden fragen wir
claudia betzin washington warum jetzt
diese truppenverlegung
die usa wollen ein klares signal der
geschlossenheit in die nato hinein aber
auch an den russischen präsidenten putin
senden ein signal der geschlossenheit
und der unbedingte bereitschaft und so
soll diese truppenverlegung auch zur
abschreckung beitragen
die us-regierung ist jetzt offenbar zu
dem schluss gekommen dass es an der zeit
sei die verteidigungsbereitschaft an der
nato ostflanke zu verstärken wobei es
sich nicht um dauerhafte
truppenverlegungen handeln soll sondern
die truppenstärke soll jeweils überprüft
und angepasst werden und ausdrücklich
wurde gesagt es werden keine truppen in
die ukraine geschickt zur begründung
sagte der pentagonsprecher dass russland
eben weiterhin nicht bereit sei zu
eskalieren sondern den truppenaufbau
fortsetze die usa hätten einen weg zur
deeskalation aufgezeigt wollen auch
weiterhin den weg der diplomatie gehen
aber eben auch für alles andere bereit
sein und sie wollen auch den sorgen der
europäischen nato partner rechnung
tragen dankeschön für diese einschätzung
aus washington claudia vates war das
seit jahren engagiert sich die
bundeswehr im afrikanischen mali zuletzt
aber gab es spannungen mit der dort
herrschenden militär unter
außenministerin baerbock stellt den
einsatz daher in frage er sei kein
selbstzweck sagte sie der süddeutschen
zeitung
derzeit ist die bundeswehr mit bis zu
1700 soldaten an einer eu mission
beteiligt auch frankreich will seinen
einsatz überdenken nachdem die hinter
vorgestern den französischen botschafter
ausgewiesen hatte
hass im internet gerade auch
politikerinnen und politiker sind davon
betroffen heute hat renate künast von
den grünen vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht einen sieg
errungen sie war 2009 10 auf facebook
mehrfach massiv und obszön beleidigt
worden jetzt kann sie darauf hoffen dass
das netzwerk die namen aller urheber
preisgeben muss sarah attacke hat
details
grünes dreckschwein und perverse
[ __ ] zwei von 22 beschimpfungen die
der grünen politikerin renate künast
2009/10 in einem shitstorm auf facebook
an den kopf geworfen wurden und
die berliner zivilgericht entscheiden
dass einige dieser beschimpfung wie
gehirn amputiert kranke frau und die
alte hat einen dachschaden nicht
beleidigend seien erst das
bundesverfassungsgericht gibt renate
künast heute umfassend recht ich freue
mich sehr über die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ich weiß dass
manche menschen ja im netz immer seine
meinungsfreiheit aber meinen sie dass
drecks [ __ ] ein ausdruck von
meinungsfreiheit ist oder die frau ist
doch krank das hat nichts mit
meinungsfreiheit zu tun es ist keine
politische debatte und auch keine
bewertung sondern es dient nur der
herabwürdigung einer person renate
künast hat damit eine grundsätzliche
entscheidung erstritten
das bundesverfassungsgericht stärkt
ausdrücklich politikern den rücken
politiker müssen sich zwar mehr gefallen
lassen als andere aber eben auch nicht
alles sie sind gerade kein freiwild
diejenigen die sich für das
allgemeinwohl einsetzen können vom staat
auch erwarten dass er sie gegen
übermäßige beschimpfungen im netz in
schutz nimmt die verfassungsrichter
haben die grenze zwischen erlaubter
kritik und strafbarem hast deutlich
gezogen jetzt ist es die schwierige
aufgabe der gerichte das auch umzusetzen
mit den kollegen von zdf heute live
spricht renate künast gleich über hass
im netz auch sie können fragen stellen
in der heute app und in unseren social
media kanälen
darf der staat schwerkranken den zugang
zu einem betäubungsmittel verschaffen
damit sie sich selbst töten können das
oberverwaltungsgericht münster sagt nein
und sieht den bundestag in der
verantwortung das problem grundsätzlich
zu regeln vor zwei jahren hatte das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
jeder mensch hat das grundrecht auf
einen selbstbestimmten tod nicht
geregelt ist wie patienten bestimmte
medikamente bekommen können christoph
schneider
harald meyer auf dem weg ins gericht der
51 jährige leitet seit 24 jahren an
multipler sklerose kann nur noch den
kopf bewegen er möchte selbst bestimmen
wann und wie sein leben enden soll noch
eine tödliche dosis natrium
pentobarbital
verweigert ihnen das
oberverwaltungsgericht nrw heute es
verwies auf andere möglichkeiten der
sterbehilfe dabei ist das gericht auch
davon ausgegangen dass es überhaupt
grundsätzlich zumutbar ist auf solche
angebote von ärzten und organisationen
verwiesen zu werden und das
gegebenenfalls auch die suche nach
geeigneten angeboten über das enge
wohnumfeld hinaus auch zb in andere
bundesländer hinaus zu denen ist harald
mayer wartet seit nunmehr fünf jahren
auf ein todbringendes medikament je
länger die wartezeit desto schlimmer
sein leiden
also im moment kommt nicht mehr vor als
freilich auf der autobahn und war
ungebremst in die stehen da hängen die
ganze welt guckt zu die zetas die sehen
dass jeder sie das herr meier bedeutet
das dass er nach wie vor keine
möglichkeit hat an der stadion
pentobarbital zu kommen die einzige
möglichkeit für ihn sich sicher zu
suizid ihren und zwar im kreise seiner
familie
ohne eine sterbehilfeorganisation in
anspruch nehmen zu müssen und ohne einen
arzt in anspruch nehmen zu müssen
verbindlich regeln könnte das alles der
gesetzgeber so die richterinnen aber
auch das bundesverwaltungsgericht wird
über seinen fall noch entscheiden
in den usa ist die abhängigkeit von
schmerzmitteln ein riesenproblem mit
etwa 100.000 toten pro jahr als
besonders betroffen gelten die meist
sozial schwachen amerikanischen
ureinwohner um klagen von mehr als 400
stimmen beizulegen haben vier große
pharmakonzerne jetzt einem vergleich
zugestimmt sie akzeptieren zahlungen von
umgerechnet etwa 525 millionen euro die
vier konzerne werden beschuldigt die
suchtgefahr der schmerzmittel
verschleiert und damit zur abhängigkeit
beigetragen zu haben
übermorgen beginnen die olympischen
winterspiele in peking heute ging es
aber bereits mit den ersten wettkämpfen
los bei aller begeisterung für die
sportlichen höchstleistungen im fokus
steht gerade fürs zdf als übertragenden
sender immer auch das politische klima
in china einen tiefen einblick in die
lebensverhältnisse gibt die
dokumentation die rivalen china versus
usa ulf röller bringt uns darin vier
menschen ganz nah
liedchen juli verwandelt sich zu einer
dragqueen damit entspricht sie nicht dem
kommunistischen männlichkeitsbild der
partei
menschen wie wir die sich outen und den
mut haben zu sich zu stehen die werden
gerne von anderen männern als weicheier
als unmöglich bezeichnet
dabei sind wir es doch die sich trauen
sich mit der regierung und der polizei
anzulegen
in china bestimmt die alte macht gerade
was männlich ist und was gedacht werden
darf die partei straft jeden ab der sich
ihr entziehen
anwalt jan kempf für menschenrechte und
wurde kurz nach unserem interview
eingesperrt
der politische ehrgeiz der
kommunistischen partei besteht darin
dass sich die rote flagge auf der ganzen
welt ausbreiten soll
die schülerin schützling wollte in den
usa studieren aber das ist in china
nicht mehr so gerne gesehen als gute
patriotin gibt sie ihren traum auf
als bürger ist es wichtig den gesetzen
zu folgen und der gesellschaft nicht zu
schaden
casey war liebt ein freies china wie er
es in hongkong kannte er musste aus der
stadt fliehen vor dem neuen
nationalismus
es sollten uns nicht zu sicher sein dass
die kommunistische partei chinas niemals
angreift
vier schicksale vier patrioten die
presse den skis angriff auf ihre
freiheit spüren
die dokumentation können sie heute abend
sehen um viertel nach zehn oder
jederzeit
das deutsche team meldet den zweiten
corona fall erstmals ist mit
eiskunstläufer nolan segert ein sportler
betroffen zwei tage noch bis zur
eröffnungsfeier heute wurde das
olympische feuer durch die chinesische
hauptstadt getragen
mehr als 1000 fackeln trägerinnen und
fackelträger werden die olympische
flamme durch peking und am freitag
schließlich ins vogelnest stadion tragen
in einer ersten deutschen
pressekonferenz formulierte der chef de
mission die deutschen erwartungen wir
haben grundsätzlich im wintersport eine
zielstellung wo wir sagen wir wollen
möglichst unter den ersten drei nationen
seien unterdessen fanden heute im
curling bereits die ersten wettkämpfe
statt dabei gelang dem chinesischen
mixed doppel gegen die schweiz mit dem
letzten stein ein hauchdünner 7 zu 6
erfolg für die gastgeber sicher genau
der richtige start in diese olympischen
winterspiele
[Applaus]
nach deutschland die fans kehren zurück
in die stadien und sporthallen die chefs
der staatskanzleien der
landesregierungen haben heute
beschlossen bundesweit dürfen bei
überregionalen veranstaltungen bis zu
10.000 zuschauer dabei sein es wird
wieder ein wenig mehr atmosphäre in die
arenen einziehen wie vom profi sport und
den liga bossen gefordert geld nun bald
bundesweit einheitliche regeln so darf
die kapazität im freien bis zu 50
prozent ausgelastet werden allerdings
sind maximal 10.000 fans pro stadion
erlaubt bei allen sportarten sind nur 30
prozent zulässig bei höchstens 4000
gästen zuvor hatten dortmund bielefeld
und köln die bisher geltende obergrenze
von 750 fans gerichtlich überprüfen
lassen nun dürfen alle klubs wieder
deutlich mehr fans reinlassen
ursprünglich sollte der plan am 19
februar fertig sein doch durch die
heutige einigung könnte der neue
beschluss sogar schon bis zum nächsten
bundesliga spieltag in kraft treten und
das wäre schon am kommenden wochenende
da würden sich doch viele drüber freuen
sicher
du hast den hochzeitstag vergessen
diesen vorwurf wollen auf nur viele
vermeiden indem sie an einprägsamen
daten wie heute heiraten der zweite
zweite 2022 hochbetrieb in den
standesämtern doch vorsicht statistiker
haben ausgerechnet wer sich an einem
schnapszahl tag das ja wort gibt hat ein
18 prozent höheres scheidungsrisiko
apropos entscheidende zahl hier sind die
vom lotto sie lauten 20 27 28 33 40 44
und die superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
das wetter bleibt ungemütlich mehr dazu
gleich von ostern terli im heute journal
um viertel vor zehn spricht christian
sievers mit bundeskanzler scholz danke
für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen und
bis morgen in siebenbürgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
eine gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die warmfront die wir hier auf
der karte sehen die bringt uns ziemlich
milde luft hinter der warmfront aber
auch regen mit und das überquert uns
allmählich nach osten ansonsten erreicht
unserem freitag diese kaltfront und die
hat einiges im gepäck schauer gewitter
und sturmböen aber wir schauen erst in
die kommende nacht da liegt die wahren
freunde einmal quer über uns bringt
regen in den höheren lagen auch schnee
bei tiefsten temperaturen von minus 1
grad nach osten hin und 7 grad ganz im
westen
am vormittag ist die warmfront noch
unterwegs über deutschland liegt immer
noch quer ja und bringt eben regen im
südwesten lockert es auf zum nachmittag
verschiebt sich der regen mit der front
weiter nach osten im nordwesten kommt
neuer regen auf im süden weiterhin
trocken mit sonnigen abschnitten mit
höchsten temperaturen von fünf grad im
vogtland und relativ milden 12 grad im
südwesten deutschlands die kommenden
tage am freitag also die kaltfront quer
über deutschland und sie wandert langsam
nach südosten
wie gesagt sturmböen sind dann dabei bei
temperaturen von fünf bis zehn grad und
auch die folgenden tage sind sehr
durchwachsen und ruppig und damit ein
schöner abend